hello everyone good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever you are
in the world thank you so much for
joining this session
i'm super happy to be here in pi data
global today i'll be giving you a talk
about sliding into causal inference with
python
we have a very packed agenda today we'll
start with an introduction i'll tell you
what i mean when i use that term sliding
and we will cover the gold standard for
causal inference and then we will spend
the majority of the talk discussing what
happens when you can't use that gold
standard so we will talk about common
reasons and we will talk about common
solutions and then finally we'll do a
quick recap about you know what we've
seen and where you can go next in your
journey into causal inference
before we dive in just a couple of words
about myself i'm a senior data scientist
at spotify for obvious reasons i'm not
going to discuss anything that i'm
working on spotify um i'm based in the
uk you can find me on twitter linkedin
github at alone
and i will admit that still i quite
often read causal inference as casual
inference and if you didn't know casual
inference is this really chill and laid
back variety of statistics
because the topic is so huge um
my approach today would be
oversimplification and exuberant hand
waving i care about giving you kind of
the intuition about you know
how certain things work and why we would
need to use that instead of
one method instead of the other and then
if you want to dive deeper the slides
and the code for this talk are already
on github so you can check it out at
your own leisure there's a lot more
detail in the appendix for this uh
talk and then you can also see the code
and follow line by line it's really kind
of simplistic and well commented i think
so you should be able to uh kind of
catch up on the nitty-gritty at your own
leisure
so let's jump into it um
when i was a wee little kid in the 90s
there was this show i really really
liked it was called sliders and slider
was about this group of friends that
they hop between parallel worlds that
guy
uh in the yellow orange jacket his name
is queen mallory super sharp guy he
invented a sliding device that opens a
portal for them to hop between parallel
universes if you didn't understand
already i'm a huge nerd um and then
every episode of the show started by
with with that guy queen mallory saying
what if you found a portal to a parallel
universe what if you could slide into a
thousand different worlds well it's the
same year and you're the same person but
everything else is different so
basically uh that was a method to
explore alternative histories they would
slide into similar worlds to
our earth
but one thing change in history that uh
kind of changed where they are now
in the 90s so for example what would a
world without penicillin would look like
what would a world where the atomic bomb
was never completed look like and so on
and so forth and i found that idea of
kind of sliding between parallel
universes and exploring alternative
history is really really cool
so today you know
you've you've probably already been
using simulations in academia and or in
industry and the question i have for you
today is well can we use python of
course to build a sliding device like
queen mallory
before we answer that question we need
to start from the basics and so for the
basics
we have this one example that we'll use
throughout the talk and that example has
to do with my girlfriend emma
this is of course an artist's depiction
of emma in reality she is much more
lovely and most of the time she's
three-dimensional which makes things
easier
and in addition to being a brilliant
woman and for putting up with me she
also likes to knit and to crochet and in
fact she is so passionate about it
that she actually not really started
selling wool online
and she called the shop not really
amazon
now
emma living with a data scientist she
decided that you know let's use data
science to expand the business make the
customers happier and so on and so forth
so
um let's get started with a randomized
control trial or an a b test that you've
probably heard of before
basically
we have two groups we want to compare so
let's assume that every month emma sends
uh her customer base a newsletter and
that newsletter always uh ends with a
big blue button that says buy it now or
check it out now like there's a call to
action
big blue button
and now what emma wants to know
what would happen if everything was the
same the same content of the email but
the color of that button would be orange
instead of blue would that
uh increase cells for example
so what we would do in an a b test a
randomized control trial maybe you've
heard of it as a multivariate
test
um which is more than just one treatment
and compared to one control um
what we do we randomly split the
customer base fifty percent get the
control the same experience as always
fifty percent get the treatment you see
how each group performed uh and the
group will uh you know that bought more
wool is declared as the winner assuming
you know strategical significance and
all that good stuff
um and and that's how the bare bones of
uh
randomized control trials work so
basically what we should always have in
mind is that we have two groups we have
control we have treatment we want to
know which one is performing better
now
this was really
kind of speeding through what the
randomized control trial is
i strongly recommend you check out check
fundoplus stock
from five years ago but it's still
experienced one of my all-time favorites
he gets into more detail now how to
compare two groups and see that the
effect is uh real
um
and what we've seen just now randomized
control trials they are known as the
gold standard in causal inference
and the reason they're the gold standard
is that because
the magic of randomization
works on observed and unobserved
covariance so an example for an observed
square it could be the city of residence
iphone versus android and so on and so
forth all sorts of
factors that might affect your decision
to to get more or less wool
and
unobserve the covariate could be for
example color blindness so obviously if
you change the color of the button
people with you know color blindness
might react differently than people who
can see colors and so if you had one
group
that was uh had a great greater
proportion
of people with color blindness
that would be a factor that play as it
comes into play when comparing it to
groups and so randomization
magically makes sure that the proportion
of color blind people would be roughly
the same between the two groups and
here's a tidbit of information for you
nails are 16 times more likely to be
colorblind than females so imagine that
you know for some reason you would have
one of the groups in the experiment be
uh had a greater proportion of men in it
than the other group then
colorblindness would come into effect
and you wouldn't even know because
that's an an observed co-founder so
that's why we use randomization
randomization guarantees
that all of those uh factors
and especially the unobserved ones are
balanced between the groups and that's
that's amazing that's the gold standard
that's what you should always strive to
so that's all nice and dandy but what
happens when you can't experiment so
there are all sorts of reasons why you
wouldn't be able to use a randomized
control trial one of them is network
effects so random effects basically
means that
you know
the
group
the the
subjects or the units of measurement in
one group affect the results of the
other group
for example if we are thinking about uh
emma's emails again let's assume that
variant the orange button
was so successful that whenev you know
whenever someone saw that email they
would immediately rush to the website
and bought a lot of wool
and if they buy so much wool that they
completely clear out the stock when
people who get the blue button want to
kind of follow the button along and buy
buy some wool they don't have any
not because they don't want to buy just
because there's none left in stock and
so
the behavior of people in the orange
group affected the outcome of the blue
group and artificially decreased it so
that's an example for network effects
and there are many others other reasons
have to do with immoral or legal
perspective for example if you want to
study the effect of
drugs on kids then you probably
shouldn't give kids drugs to see what
happens
and there are other practical
perspectives like
budget or
user experience and so on and so forth
so
what can we do i want you to keep in
mind that what we strive to what we want
to do is to use the gold standard we
want to have a group of control people
and could group of treatment people and
compare them and you would see
in this little graphics that the groups
are
heterogeneous right you don't see they
are roughly looking the same you don't
see people with you know
more people wearing red in one group of
the other and so on and so forth
so with that in mind what we are going
to look at is two examples
one of them will see
um what do we do when the allocation to
control and treatment is not random when
it's biased when it's skewed
and how do we fix that to
be more similar to what we want it to
look like the randomized control trial
and then we'll start with that and then
we'll
turn our attention to cases where
you don't have a control group because
everyone gets the treatment but that's
uh to come in a few seconds
so um back to amazon let's imagine that
every order on amazon contains exactly
one ball of wool
delivery fee is two pounds flat per
order and things are a steady state so
nothing changes uh if you bought five
balls before last month you'll buy five
this months and five the next month and
five the month after that and so on and
so forth
now emma introduces a new service called
amazon sublime again not real
and amazon sublime is a subscription
service that offers you unlimited free
delivery on every order if you pay an 11
pounds a month subscription fee
so
how does that affect the business so
let's do what we always do we have
control we have treatment we'll compare
the two so
they're treated here are sublime
subscribers we see that they order 13
times a month
we look at people that don't have
sublime they order 4.7 times a month on
average we see the difference is almost
200 percent so sublime is a huge success
or maybe it's not so let's kind of have
a closer look let's look at the
distribution of orders
before sublime was introduced
and very conveniently you can see that
we have exactly 10 000
customers and they are uniformly
distributed between one and ten orders a
month so you have a thousand people that
order once a month a thousand people who
order twice a month and so on and so
forth
and they are very neatly uniformly
distributed and now let's see what it
looks like after the introduction of
sublime so the horizontal axis is again
the number of monthly orders before
sublime was introduced and the vertical
axis is the
number of monthly orders after it was
introduced
so very easily you can see that only
people who previously again remember to
look at the horizontal line
uh
ordered six or more times they're only
they are the only people who got sublime
which makes sense if you ordered six or
more times a month at two pounds per
delivery
then you would pay 12 months 12 pounds
or more a month on just delivery so
getting uh an 11 pounds a month free
delivery subscription program makes
sense
and for the same reason people who order
five or less time
times a month wouldn't get the
subscription because they are already
spending less than 11 pounds for
deliveries
and if we kind of go back and look at
those highly engaged users of six to ten
orders a month we can see that 50 of
them
got sublime and 50 didn't change their
behavior they didn't get sublime so um
big bullets are uh representing a
thousand people smaller ones i got 500
blue
is
kind of the before red or without
sublime and uh red is with sublime
so um
let's take our rulers out and see well
those lines seem fairly parallel and you
know what actually the difference is
five orders so how did we get 8.3
well the reason we got 8.3 is that we
made an unfair comparison
highly engaged users
self-selected themselves to become
sublime members it wasn't a randomized
controlled trial
people who had more orders a month prior
to sublime are the only ones that would
even consider getting it so we didn't
have what we wanted to have you know
similar groups of controlling trial and
when we compelled uh people who got
sublime to all the people who didn't get
sublime we made an unfair comparison
which artificially uh diminished or
decreased the number for the untreated
what we should have done is to compare
those two groups the two groups that
were even eligible would even consider
sublime so
this is what we needed to do uh those
two oval shapes we needed to compare
people with high free engagement prior
to sublime and high enragement uh post
sublime and see what they behave like
and the way we do that is with a
technique called propensity score
matching propensity score matching is
fairly simple
at least theoretically there are four
steps first of all you learn a model
that predicts the
propensity a user or you know any unit
of measurement
in your experiment would get the
treatment
then you match
every user that was treated to a user
that wasn't treated that has a similar
propensity score
then you compare kind of calculate the
delta between the two and when you do
that for every user then you can find
the average effect size for everyone um
and we have code which is again in on
github so we don't really need to kind
of follow along um
i basically have the same parameters
as that we saw in the slides before we
have 5 000 people with low engagement
5000 with high engagement the
probability of getting sublime if you're
highly engaged is one half
and uplift
is exactly five orders flat
and then kind of stating those facts
then we can start building
um our kind of simulated data and we can
see that if we do some quick group buys
we can see that if you order between one
and five the percent that converted is
absolutely zero exactly zero and if you
ordered six or more times it's roughly
fifty percent it's not exactly fifty
percent here because we use simulated
data
and then we kind of the meaty part is
kind of just learning a logistic model
to predict the propensity they would get
the treatment so your regular vanilla
escalante logistic regression
um and then if we plot stuff we see
that the model picked up
that people who have higher frequency
are more likely to get sublime
so
that that shape is not ideal what we
would expect it to look like is this the
blue
teal green bars
that show that you know it's 50
flat after six
orders and not gradually uh going up but
that actually is good enough for our
example and i would challenge you to
think of why
so we do that and then we do the
matching and you'll follow along at home
and believe it or not we get exactly
five orders difference and so
everybody's happy um and i know this was
hand-wavy so i would encourage you to go
to the repo and check it out yourselves
and be convinced because the code is
fairly straightforward
so just to recap
we saw that we have two groups uh
treated and untreated but they are not
want randomly si
assigned because there was self
selection people self-selecting
themselves to get the treatment which
caused
some inflation for the effects
and we use
propensity score matching to fix that to
emulate a random assignment which is
exactly what we wanted again think about
the two groups control and treatment
similar groups
uh so you could compare them and this
was a very simple example of uh
propensity score matching because we
only had one covariate the number of
orders prior to uh
the introduction of sublime but in
reality you would have many variants and
if you think about the curse of
dimensionality the more covariance you
add then propensities commenting is a
really really useful technique because
it reduces all of those dimensions to
one number to match on and that's the
beauty of the methodology
so
uh i hope that was clear we just saw
what you do when the allocation to
control and treatment is not random now
let's talk about what happens when
you don't have a control group you only
have a treatment group what do you do
then
so again we go to amazon and let's
pretend that all of that previous
section didn't happen let's throw away
off the assumption assumptions that we
introduced earlier there is no sublime
nothing
and
we kind of
look more
deeply into emma's
business and she actually has five
product lines five different types of
wool green blue magenta and so on and we
assume that each of those product lines
has their own distinct group of
customers so there are people who buy
only green wall there are other people
that would only buy blue wool and so on
and so on so those groups of people are
independent of each other if i buy green
wool i only buy green wool i don't buy
any of the other colors and so and the
same applies for the other color color
and they are completely again
independent they don't
the behavior of one group of customers
of one color does not affect in any way
the behavior of other colors all right i
hope that makes sense
and if we look at the kind of the
purchasing frequency we can see that
greenwall uh customers place an average
of five orders a month blue three and so
on and so forth
now here's the interesting part let's
say that emma decided to offer free
delivery for everyone buying green wool
and again
only people who buy green wool would be
affected other groups would not be they
are completely independent they are
completely oblivious they are just doing
their own thing
so
what do we do how would we how would
free delivery affect the number of
orders of green wool
that people make a month if we don't
have a control group everyone gets free
delivery
right so here's what we want to do we
want to have a group of control a group
of treatments they would roughly look
the same and we want to compare them but
unfortunately we just don't have that
control group
what can we do
what we would want to do in a dl award
is to say well i have this customer here
are the number of orders they placed
with
the free delivery promotion here's the
number of orders they would have placed
without the free delivery they calculate
the difference and we kind of can
estimate the average treatment effect or
the effect size
so that would be an ideal award but
unfortunately in reality
we only observe one outcome we only know
how many orders each customer from the
green group actually placed we don't
know how much they would have placed if
they didn't have free delivery again
remember we threw away all of the
assumptions from the previous example so
we don't assume a steady state for the
green
customers anymore for example
um and and this problem is known as the
fundamental problem of causal inference
because we can only observe one outcome
per person we don't know what would have
been the outcome has the person been
under different circumstances that's the
biggie so what can we do we have all
sorts of techniques to handle that we
have pre and post analysis we have
difference and then difference
both of these are
covered in the appendix
of this talk they're very
straightforward so i don't bother kind
of
going over them now but i do encourage
you to check them out on github and what
we will talk about is this technique
called synthetic controls which is
our version of a sliding device which is
which is pretty cool
so
what if we could build our own sliding
device it would show us a parallel world
where all of those people who got the
treatment
didn't get it
all right and what uh synthetic control
does it basically creates a counter
factual reality what would have happened
and even if you don't have one good
control group what it does it uh waits
other
uh time series other
potential controls that even though not
one of them is a very good control group
by itself
it assigns weights to learn
how would a confectual group would have
behaved and uses that to predict or to
find the the changing behavior so this
was kind of high level so hopefully um
you'll understand by the uh in a sec so
if i were to throw you back into your
nursery days or kindergarten days you
would remember that if you wanted to
create green color and you didn't have
any then you would just mix 50
you know blue and 50 yellow and you
would get green right that's elementary
like uh nursery skills
and we need zero magenta zero red we
would still if we could just get take
fifty percent of blue fifty percent of
the yellow we would get green which is
great
and the numbers kind of worked working
and walking out uh these are the numbers
i showed you previously and very
conveniently
if you take fifty percent of three and
fifty percent of seven you would get
five
so things
kind of make sense
um in code again not gonna bother going
through all of this
we again kind of create the same
kind of
starting conditions with a lot of
randomness and simulated data
we do some descriptive statistics to see
that you know actually things are the
way we want them to
uh
things behave the way that we wanted
them to behave so green has an average
of five orders blue seven ish and yellow
three
and then you know uh we can we are good
to keep going and the way we'll
implement synthetic controls is with
this very nice and handy library from
the good people at google called causal
impact and what coastal epic does is
uses black magic and bayesian structure
time series is completely well beyond
the scope of that of the stock and what
they do is they kind of
learn uh they use time series of
different control groups they weighed
them to create a counterfactual and
this is what some of the outputs look
like so what are we seeing here so we
have a dashed line that shows the time
of treatment
and we have a
solid black line which is the green
order so before the treatment
they are around five after the treatment
they go up to seven but we'll get to
that in a sec the dashed lines with the
purple um bands
are the counter factual so basically a
mix of other colors
that if is that we can see that in the
period before the treatment
they are doing well fairly similar to
what uh green actually looks like
and then we have the treatment green
goes up to seven and uh the
counterfactual again kind of the dashed
line with the purple bands
stays the same because it didn't see the
treatment so we are using the same
weights that would lend in the period
before the treatment
and apply them to those groups the
yellow and blue ones
after the trooping two and that allows
us to find the difference hope that
makes sense this was a super simple
example how to
construct a counterfactual
this was so simple that in fact it was
wrong and i challenged you to find why
it's wrong there is more
information on the github repo
when you get it you get it and i'm i'm
more than happy to chat further
offline
so i hope you enjoyed this
talk so far let's just do a quick recap
before we break we saw we started by
seeing the randomized controlled trials
which is the gold standard we talked
about what happens when we don't have a
truly random allocation to control and
variant and then we discussed what
happens when you actually don't even
have a control group
and next up you can kind of uh if you
want to explore or dive deeper into the
world of causal inference you can
think about breadth and depth so
so many topics we didn't cover like
different div dags instrumental
variables uh fixed effect progressions
and and so on and so on there's a lot to
learn and you can also kind of uh dive
deeper into one specific topic like psm
so with psms we didn't uh discuss how do
we know that the groups are balanced
after we do the matching
how do we match what what function what
algorithm we do do we use for matching
um
should we match with or without a
replacement and so on and so on there's
all sorts of considerations as there's a
lot more to talk about
uh when it comes to pcms for example or
any of those
so just to leave you off we discussed
the fundamental problem of causal
inference i would like you to remember
that even though we have you know fancy
math shiny tools we will never know
if the number we came out with is
actually true because we will never
observe that counterfactual earth so
just keep that in mind here are a few
links uh if you want to learn more and i
would like to thank you very much for
joining i uh really hope that you enjoy
this talk thank you very much and i hope
to keep the conversation going offline
thank you